this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespaces the all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below and more on them in a bit
quick question how often have you seen a
new president enter office with a sack
full of promises only to immediately
break the entire lot of them well that
number probably corresponds to the
number of presidents you lived under
from george h.w bush's no new taxes to
obama failing to close gitmo the white
house has a long tradition of
over-promising and delivering yet there
was one president who bucked this trend
a man who on entering office promised
four specific things achieved them all
and then left after a single term that
man was james k polk and he was arguably
the most successful president in u.s
history at the moment polk was
inaugurated in 1845 a movement was
underway to increase america's territory
declaring that it expands the nation
westward polk quickly took the u.s from
a nation of 1.7 million square miles to
nearly three million it was polk who
brought in texas california oregon
territory polk who ordered the u.s to
stretch from sea to shining sea but all
this giddy expansion came at a price
polk may have left the u.s greatly
enlarged but he also left it standing on
the brink of catastrophe
the life james knox polk was born into
on november 2nd 1795 was one for which
only the term hardy could suffice born
in a log cabin in rural north carolina
polg was the first of an incredible ten
children all of whom his mother would
raise in a strict calvinist faith that
meant little fun and a lot of hard work
as an adult polkwood overworked to the
point of exhaustion unable to escape the
feeling that arrest was somehow wicked
yet compared to the rest of his
childhood work was almost a respite when
the boy was 10 his family upped sticks
and moved to the tennessee frontier
where his father was determined to carve
out a plantation for over 500 miles the
family traveled on rough roads via
wagons subjecting themselves to all
sorts of deprivations it was on this
journey that the future president began
to suffer the ill health that would
plague him for his life and given how
bad things got actual plague
would have probably been preferable as a
teen for example polk was forced to
undergo surgery for his illness with no
anesthetic and no antibiotics the
surgeon simply gave him some brandy and
then sliced his urinary tract open and
sewed him back up all while the boy
presumably screamed still the move to
tennessee did at least change the
family's fortunes the new plantation
grew to thousands of acres tendered by
50 slaves as the polks came up in the
world they began to rub shoulders with
the great and good of the state the
greatest of whom was no doubt andrew
jackson a living military legend old
hickory was already famous for his
controversial wars and role in
tennessee's expansion he was also about
to become the biggest most divisive
thing in american politics in other
words exactly the sort of personality an
ambitious young man might want to hitch
themselves to a young man like james
polk it's uncertain exactly when polk
and jackson first met but it can't have
been long after the young man returned
from university in north carolina
initially settling in nashville to
practice law polk quickly set his sights
on politics picking up a side gig
clerking in the state senate it was here
that he fell decisively into the orbit
of democratic republicans likely the
single most powerful party in u.s
history by 1823 the democratic
republican party was headed towards its
seventh election victory in a row a feat
still unmatched in american politics but
as the party reached a quarter century
in power the lack of opposition had
become a curse fishers were starting to
erupt that threatened to engulf
everything it would be from the ashes of
these political wildfires that polk's
washington career was born for now the
future president concentrated on local
politics winning election to tennessee's
state house of representatives there he
made perhaps the shrewdest decision of
his life tennessee was in need of a new
senator to send to washington although
he was aligned with a different faction
polk wound up casting his vote for a
grateful andrew jackson it seems the
young man was already able to read the
political winds within a year those
winds had become an oncoming storm in
1824 four different candidates claimed
the mantle of democratic republican
nominee among them was andrew jackson
down in tennessee polk campaigned
ferociously for his new friend
delighting when he gains the largest
share of the popular vote but since none
of the four managed to win outright it
held a congress to pick the next
president to polk and jackson's outrage
they went with second place finisher
john quincy adams yet the result would
be a blessing in disguise when the next
election rolled around old hickory would
be able to use outrage generated by
adams's corrupt wind to propel himself
to the very top and his new protege
would be riding along right beside him
the same year he lost the presidency by
a whisker andrew jackson gave polk
perhaps the best piece of advice the
young man would ever receive to get
married see the thing we haven't
mentioned is that james polk was a dude
who was incredibly hard to like austere
dower prone to overwork awful at
conversation and uninterested in
anything but politics polk was like your
nightmare tinder date a sexless boring
man who couldn't charm his way out of a
paper bag which is why his 1824 marriage
to sarah chadrus was such a gift the
rich daughter of politically connected
slave owners sarah was a born socialite
the sort of woman who could work a room
so well that everyone would leave
wanting to do exactly as she had
suggested as polk's wife sarah used
every ounce of this charm to help
nurture and expand her husband's
tennessee power base in no time at all
that base was flourishing in 1825 polk
abandoned the state legislature taking a
run at the house of representatives he
won handily the first of seven terms
that it served in washington and that
gave him a ringside seat to the biggest
electoral storm in decades the 1828
election saw jackson's comeback netting
the victory denied four years earlier at
the head of the newly created democratic
party he crushed john quincy adams
taking 55 percent of the popular vote
inaugurated the following march jackson
entered the white house like a hurricane
ready to smash the old order to pieces
personally james k polk couldn't wait
rather than just being jackson's ally in
the house polk became the seventh
president's lieutenant the guy who'd go
to bat for him no matter what bat crazy
thing jackson was slinging every single
idea that jackson put forward polk
defended to the hilt helping whip his
fellow representatives into following
the president his colleagues made fun of
him calling him young hickory made out
that he was jackson's puppet but polk
was more than that it may have been
ambition that initially hitched him to
this brash populist but it was something
else that made him stay for polk
jacksonian democracy wasn't just an idea
it was a movement a movement that
actively expanded the electorate that
spoke for the people and the people
couldn't get enough of it re-elected in
1832 jackson was by now starting to
consider polk the son that he'd never
had he backed his protege to become
speaker of the house before ensuring
that polk would keep that position even
after he stepped down as president a
promise made easy when his hand-picked
successor martin van buren won in 1836.
for polk this was an era where he rode
the zeitgeist to the crest of a popular
wave that looked set to keep rolling for
eternity also it must have seemed in
truth jackson's policies especially
regarding banking had set the economy on
a crash course and his divisive manner
had sparked a massive backlash in his
home state in 1835 in 1837 anti-jackson
politicians won the tennessee governor's
mansion in 1836 the state voted against
van buren worried about the rebellion in
his backyard polk quit the house
returned home and in 1839 ran for
governor on an openly jacksonian
platform his shock win was supposed to
turn the tide to show this wave was
never going to stop sweeping the nation
instead polk's victory turned out to be
a mere breather before the wave dumped
him naked shivering and broken
onto reality's stony shore by 1840 the
jackson experiment had failed the
economy was being hammered people were
going bankrupt and life tasted of ash
and bitterness that same year the whig
party under william henry harrison beat
the democrats at the polls just 12
months later polk was booted from the
tennessee governor's mansion when he
tried to retake it in 1843 he failed
spectacularly with jackson's movement
floundering and the wigs and ascendants
polk suddenly found himself cast adrift
he returned to the family plantation
wondering if maybe that was it if his
time at the top had already come and
gone he needn't have worried in 12
months the wig's seemingly unstoppable
rise was going to splutter and stall and
when it did it would be young hickory
could be ready to replace them now just
before we get into the rest of today's
video i do want to say that this one is
brought to you by squarespace this is
the age of creation think about it
everybody is out there on the internet
making something online whether it's a
tick-tock dancer youtube video or a
fantastic website and look if you want
to make a fantastic website the right
way to do that is with our friends over
at squarespace squarespace is the
perfect web tool to fashion the internet
into whatever you want it to be maybe
the hands-on type he's got lots of
opinions and ideas about what exactly
your website should look like if so very
cool squarespace gives you all of the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about nobody wants
any of that nonsense or maybe you just
need something functional something that
works with minimal thought so that you
can stay focused on the content and not
the coat of paint if so just use one of
their quick beautiful templates to make
a website that's both fresh and simple
and once you're done setting up your
website locking in the name maybe
playing with some of the colors there
are so many extra features that
squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member-only areas analytics commercial
options 24 7 customer support really
everything you need is in one place so
when you're ready to get started on next
project of yours big or small if it
involves a website it's gotta be
squarespace right now you can go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll say 10 of your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and now back to today's video
at this stage you might be wondering how
the hell pog is going to transition from
moping around in tennessee to leading
the united states in
a single year and the answer could be
summed up with one word
texas seven years earlier texas had
seceded from mexico establishing an
independent republic not that the u.s
wanted it to remain independent though
this was the era of manifest destiny a
term coined in 1845 that expressed
americans desire to expand westward
starting with the annexation of texas
the problem was mexico still wanted
their wayward province back so rather
than risk war washington quietly avoided
the issue but then john tyler came along
and screwed everything up the 10th
president tyler had taken over from
william henry harrison after the latter
died in office nominally a wig tyler was
such an unwick-like president that his
party hated him knowing he'd never get
re-nominated in 1844 tyler began
desperately casting about for a popular
issue to boost his run as an independent
and nothing was more popular than
wanting to annex texas tyler's
pro-annexation stance effectively turned
the democratic party on its head
beforehand martin van buren have been
expected to run again but tyler's
announcement made taxes such a hot issue
that van buren had to weigh in and that
was a problem because while van buren
would lose southern democrats if he came
out as anti-annexation he'd lose his
home state of new york if he came out as
pro slavery you see was still legal in
texas if texas was admitted to the union
the delicate balance between slave and
free states would be destroyed van
buren's one slim hope was to oppose
annexation then hope southern democrats
after a whole lot of moaning would rally
behind him rather than let the whigs win
the election sadly he misjudged how
willing southerners were to play nice
with him at the 1844 democratic
convention the ballot deadlocked there
was no majority for anti-annexation van
buren but his rival louis cass couldn't
quite win either on the eight ballot
someone suggested throwing in a
compromise candidate to break the tie
someone known for his party loyalty
someone who might be i don't know
chilling down in tennessee right now
only dimly aware of all of this drama
the moment polk's name was added van
buren knew that the game was over rather
than let cass become eventual victor he
threw all of his supporters behind the
new guy at 2pm on may 30 1844 polk
became the democratic nominee it would
take word nearly a week to reach
tennessee it reached washington that
same day though thanks to a newly
installed telegraph and the dudes in
washington found the whole thing
hilarious polk was such a nobody the
newspapers declared who is james k polk
the whigs responded by putting up their
best man henry clay knowing it to be a
cakewalk sadly for clay it turns out the
answer to who was james k polk was
one clever son of a polk's genius
was to embrace texas annexation while
also throwing northerners a bone what if
oregon territory then jointly
administered with britain also joined
the union since any new oregon state
would probably be free the delicate
balance in congress would be preserved
all while fulfilling america's manifest
destiny that tricky needle threaded all
polk had to do was sit back and watch
the opposition flounder unwilling to
annex texas all the wigs could do was
try to portray themselves as the
anti-slavery party a hypocritical
position since their nominee owned
slaves it was this simple fact that
spelled henry clay's doom when the
election results finally came in polk
could won the popular vote by a mere 38
000 ballots one of the narrowest
victories in u.s history painfully for
the wigs clay lost just enough votes in
new york to the hardcore anti-slavery
liberal party to put polk over the top
had clay won the state had squeaked an
electoral college victory age just 49
polk was set to become america's then
youngest president in doing so he set
the entire nation on a collision course
with destiny
so back in the intro we mentioned how
polk entered the white house with four
specific promises so well now might be a
good time to get them on our checklist
for ticking off later the first two
you're already familiar with one annex
texas two take over the oregon territory
the other two were a little bit more
obscure three lower tariff rates and
four establish an independent u.s
treasury short as this list was it was
also a tall order especially since poll
had already said he only wanted to serve
one term if he wanted to become
america's most successful president polk
was going to have to act fast luckily
where one item was concerned at least
congress was already raring to go one of
the very first things polk did in office
was to sign off on congress's joint
resolution to annex texas that paved the
way for the lone star state to join the
union in december 1845 providing polk
with an early win the eleventh president
then immediately turned his attention to
the other chunk of territory that he
wanted oregon back in 1818 the u.s and
britain had agreed to join the occupy
oregon country modern-day oregon
washington idaho and british columbia
this had worked well for a couple of
decades but as more and more americans
started flooding in on the oregon trail
and manifest destiny slowly became a
thing people began to wonder well why
why were they sharing this prime piece
of real estate with a bunch of limey
douchebags when they could just take it
for themselves a movement even sprang up
to annex the territory all the way up to
what was then russian alaska's southern
border at the latitude of 54 degrees 40
minutes spawning the jingoistic slogan
54-40 or fight in his campaign polk had
capitalized on this feeling promising to
take oregon territory with a year of
being elected but now he was actually
president that whole or fight bit it was
starting to look a bit drastic no one
wanted a bunch of redcoats marching down
from canada and setting the white house
on fire again especially not when mexico
was clearly gearing up for a war over
texas so polk did the only thing he
could he cut a deal dropping the whole
54 degrees thing american negotiators
contacted the british wondering if they
might not accept a slightly less
offensive border with the british also
super not into the idea of turning the
war of 1812 into an ongoing franchise a
deal was quickly reached oregon country
would be divided along the 49th parallel
with a slight deviation at the end to
allow the whole of vancouver island to
remain in canada and that's how without
a shot being fired the modern pacific
northwest joined the usa the oregon
treaty came into force on june 15 1846
less than a year and a half into his
term and polk had already fulfilled his
second campaign promise well actually it
fulfilled all four the first half of
1846 also saw polk first convince
congress to lower tariffs and then to
establish an independent treasury his
other two major pledges but while the
president's program was technically
complete he didn't have time to
celebrate by the time the oregon treaty
was being signed the texas issue had
already come to a head the united states
and mexico were now at war by the time
the carnage ended the political map of
north america would have changed forever
in late april 1846 mexican troops
crossed the rio grande determined to
deal with the invaders in their nation's
north it was now a few months since
texas had joined the u.s an act mexico's
leaders felt should have led to war but
didn't but letting texas go was one
thing it was quite another to let
enemies occupy mexican soil at last the
mexican troops found the american
intruders an opening fire they killed 12
before retreating as they slipped back
across the river the soldiers must have
felt a sense of triumph americans had
occupied their soil and paid the price
but that wasn't how the americans saw it
as far as they were concerned mexico had
just invaded texas at the moment texas
became part of the usa it had a disputed
border with mexico an area between the
rio grande and the news's river that
both side claimed as their own not long
after texas was annexed polk could send
a special envoy to mexico city to settle
the border claim but it also ordered
troops into the disputed zone under
general zachary taylor for some this act
is final proof that polk deliberately
wanted to provoke a conflict if that's
the case well he got his wish two weeks
after the ambush that killed 12 u.s
troops congress authorized war with
mexico it was the beginning of the
mexican-american war but it was no
longer just about texas if it ever had
been under the guise of conflict polk
was about to push through one of the
biggest expansions that the u.s would
ever experience back in 1845 polkadot
dispatched charles freeman west to
survey some land around mexican-owned
alta california survey in air quotes
there because freeman was really heading
an invasion force come may 1846 that
force was lying low on the edge of
mexican territory steadfastly being
brutally murderous dicks to the local
native americans when word arrived at
their april ambush without even waiting
to confirm if congress had declared war
freeman led his small force into
california rallying white settlers to
his side as they marched by june 14th
the tiny mexican garrison protecting the
entire departmento had surrendered just
a few weeks later the navy appeared off
the coast and declared california u.s
territory it would take another month or
so to iron out the details but america
was at last beginning to stretch from
sea to shining sea you can see here why
some people think polk was a tricky son
of a he 100 knew about freeman's
planned invasion and it's extremely
likely that he triggered the war as a
cover for it yet who can argue with the
results between december of 1845 and
july of 1846 the 11th president added
not just texas and oregon territory to
america's portfolio but also california
and there was still more to come over
the next year and a half mexico was
comprehensively defeated the disputed
texas territory occupied its capital
attacked and its government overthrown
if we ever get around to launching a war
or graphics channel and spoiler alert
that totally might be happening we'd
love to talk you through all of the
highlights from winfield scott's march
from veracruz to santa ana's hilarious
and predictable double crossing of well
everybody for today's story though you
only really need to know the outcome
major history spoiler though
mexico lost in washington the jingoism
unleashed by mexico's defeat was so
great that some democrats called for
polk to annex the entire country
serenity now the president managed to
deflect their demands but not by much
the 1848 treaty of guadalupe hidalgo
exceeded even the warmongerer's wildest
expectations not only did it set texas
border at the rio grande and organize a
payment to mexico in exchange for
california it also contained provisions
for the u.s to take new mexico known as
the mexican session it increased the
size of the usa by one-fourth giving
washington the modern states of arizona
nevada utah new mexico and california
plus bits of wyoming and colorado for
polk the treaty was its ultimate triumph
it was now nearly four years since it
assumed the presidency four years in
which it fulfilled all his pledges and
turned manifest destiny into concrete
reality shaw had taken 63 000 dead in a
nasty war sure it
cleared the way for a wave of indigenous
killings across newly acquired
california one that would grow so vast
it's today considered a genocide but
from the president's perspective it'd
have been worth it america's future was
now secure sadly the same can be said
for polks
[Music]
when pog fulfilled his promise in 1848
to step aside after one term it must
have seemed like he'd go down in history
as one of the greatest presidents for a
while he did after all he'd grown the
country and won a war so why isn't that
the case anymore why did the last survey
of presidential historians in 2021 place
him 18th on par with bill clinton for
that you can blame the massive pandora's
box that polk opened with his drive west
the one that ruined every president's
reputation in his era the box marked
slavery there's no point sugar coating
it james pog owned dozens of slaves
while he'd request that they'd be freed
in his will he never had the moral
courage do it himself of course polk
wasn't alone in this half of congress in
this era consisted of slavers and
therein lay the biggest problem as polk
drove america worst both pro and
anti-slavery advocates began to wonder
if this wasn't all a scheme to bring in
new slave states and shut the
abolitionists out of power as early as
1846 flights were erupting in congress
over the new states with bills
alternately banning and expanding the
south's peculiar appalling institution
the court between competing currents in
his own party and his own unsteady
beliefs polk tried weak compromises
suggesting the missouri compromise line
be extended clear to the pacific but
such dithering made nobody happy by 1848
slavery had become the defining issue of
the era by paving the way for a host of
new states without settling the slavery
question poll kelp pushed his nation a
step closer to the coming abyss while it
would take a string of failed presidents
to lead it over the edge there's no
denying the polk's failure to address
this explosive issue undermines his
claim to greatness still as polk left
office he could look back on four
transformative years beyond his
fulfilled promises there was the
creation of the department of the
interior the treaty signed with new
granada modern-day colombia giving the
u.s right of way across panama the first
step towards the eventual creation of
the panama canal had overseen iowa and
wisconsin joining the union stabilized
the economy averted war with britain all
heady important stuff sure he had to
watch as the whig party under zachary
taylor won the 1848 election but still
for a one-term wonder he was unequaled
sadly paul didn't get to rest on his
laurels for long ill from overwork when
he stepped down polk embarked on a
vacation a tour of the south to bask in
the public's affection while in new
orleans the newly retired president felt
deathly ill most likely the result of a
cholera outbreak then gripping the city
thinking it was just a flare-up of his
lifelong problems polk cut his journey
short and returned to nashville there he
died on june 15 1849 after the shortest
retirement in presidential history fast
forward to today and polk occupies a
weird space in the popular imagination
generally beloved by those who know of
him almost invisible to everyone else
certainly there's a lot to love how many
other presidents have willingly stood
down after a single term how many others
have entered the oval office with such
clear goals and achieved all of them yet
for his personal integrity and
intelligence james k polk maybe falls
short of being great too let down by the
slavery issue by the later calamities he
indirectly helped cause great or not
though pog was a visionary if you live
in one of the 13 odd states he brought
into the u.s you're still living that
vision today because make no mistake
polk was massively consequential whether
we love him or we loathe him we should
all at least agree to remember him
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]